from the post-millennial Marjorie Taylor
green brings resolution to censure ilhan
Omar over treasonous statements I do
believe this story shows us the tensions
between the political factions I also
believe it shows um a lot of its for
show I got to be honest censure for
treason is that a joke everything
Republicans do is for show none of it it
doesn't mean anything how many of them
have introduced articles of impeachment
against Biden right right Democrats did
the same but I mean like dude if you
actually thought had an impeachment
trial we've just like been like I'm
going to impeach you and I'm going to
impeach you yeah if Marjorie Taylor
green and I I'd like to talk to her
about this but I'm going to say right
now if you genuinely think it's
treasonous I think the resolution would
be for a criminal referral in the
immediate and an expulsion from
Congress I see your point yeah followed
by criminal
charges for which the penalty is of for
treason is but I think it's 10 years in
prison or death right that's a bold
thing to claim some scale I will say
Absolut yeah it is it's a wide range
it's like we're going to give you a
written warning for TR but the right the
right is playing the same games as the
left like they're taking important words
and killing them right like Tre oh I
know that's why I keep getting mad when
people say it's treason I'm like no it's
sedition right and it's like I
understand there's an overlap but Biden
breaking the southern border which is
bringing a bunch of random people from
different countries that's destroying
the nation that's sedici that is
destroying the fabric of the nation
treason would be like he met with an
organized body that the it would be so
it could it could be treason right like
if Joe Biden goes to the Cartal and says
we're going to give you everything you
everything you want that's a traitor to
this country yes they have betrayed the
country to our enemies right there's an
overlap though I get it but yeah but no
like Benedict Arnold was selling West
Point to the Brit to the British you
know they caught they caught the one guy
and they hang that guy uh and and Arnold
got away and they put him in a nice uh
grave in the bottom of a cathedral
all I'm hearing is like the scoobydoo
like and I would have gotten away with
it
too well there's also uh Ben Franklin's
son you know Ian Ian brought this up he
was a loyalist and he he fled to I
believe he fled to London where he was
like those people are nuts yeah yeah
it's crazy it's wild but Benedict got
away with a lot of stuff and um you know
he was married to a loyalist and he was
a a war vet who was he felt like he
wasn't awarded enough from his time at
Battle and so he just like I'm going to
sell West Point and I didn't work out he
said I live by my own rules goodbye he
He Turned West Point like the biggest
battle point of you know it was holding
down the Hudson River and he turned it
into a literal pigy and then when George
Washington came by he was like what
happened here where's Benedict Arnold go
get Benedict Arnold and then his wife
put on a whole display crying fake
crying so they say so Benedict could get
down onto the HMS vulture and take off
wow it's crazy and he ladies that is
loyal that's treason yeah right so right
now you've got cartels NOS human
Smugglers and I think there is an
argument to be made for treason but I I
I think it's too strong in that we're
not at war with some stupid NGO they're
just committing crimes right you arrest
the people who are doing it Biden's just
not doing that so I'd say that's
sedition but again more to the point I I
actually I this is really funny actually
let me play this video for you uh this
is good represent got here we go
centuring representative ilhan Omar of
Somali I mean Minnesota okay bravo bravo
on that one maybe that's why she wasn't
sure what she was bringing her up on
charge she's like I just got this good
line I got to get this to the floor
quick I I think there is a question
though and a fair argument to be
argument to be had everybody's really
mad about illan Omar saying you know my
president and Somali and all that and uh
I mean there's a lot of people who are
like we will fight for Israel we will do
what Israel whatever they need you know
it is a holy land I mean there's been
politicians who have said on par things
I don't like any of them to be to be
fair I I'm not sure that any of the
politicians who have pledged support to
Israel have outright said that they are
Israelis who are serving Israel but they
have said like we will give them what
whatever they want haven't some of them
worn like the the flag or or even
uniforms yeah pretty sure people like
they War like American flag in Israel
right and so I mean there's there's a
question of like hey man I got to be
honest I'm not a fan of any of it yeah
like I I don't like the us spending all
its money on on foreign countries and
all this Aid right right and Israel gets
a lot of it yeah so everyone's mad at
ilhan Omar but I'm kind of like okay I
mean Fair Point what's your position on
Israel cuz like I think Israel's a right
to defend itself all that stuff I think
uh you know what Hamas did is bad I
think Hamas should be wiped out all that
stuff I just don't like our politicians
acting like this country is somehow
deserved of everything we have to give
it I'm like well it's another country
they're entitled to their rights their
natural rights their self-defense all
that good stuff I think it's a beautiful
country too uh that being said there are
a lot of people who are are adamant on
providing Military Support massive
amounts of money and fine if that's your
argument I'll listen but why be mad at
ilhan Omar who wants the same thing but
for a different country I to me I think
that there's just a general
attitude with her there's this ongoing
sort of rhetoric about uh a hatred of
America and our values and that things
seem to change and that we're inherently
racist and we're inherently white
supremacist and things like that so I
think when someone like her shows an
allegiance to where she comes from it
lands differently than I think somebody
who actually has a love and respect for
America but
also wants to support yeah like I I I do
recognize there's a big difference
between saying something like Israel
will get our military support is an ally
in the region and being like I'm Somali
from Somalia and I love my president
you're like wait a minute yeah and this
country Su team I feel like you don't
remember where we are right now yeah
like if someone in Congress said that
you know Netanyahu was their boss or
whatever we we'd take that that's a step
too far some people I got to be honest
though there have been I think Lauren
might have been Lauren bobbert saying
something like it was a holy land I I
don't want to put words in people's
mouths but there have been members of
Congress who have said like this is the
holy land we'll defend it and we're
going to work with Israel to do so and
things like that yeah I mean I've said
this a couple times but uh when JFK was
President everyone was like well he's
Catholic so his ultimate Allegiance is
to the pope and can we have that and he
had to give a public address he had to
you know preex putting out the threads
addressing things he had to give speech
saying like this is how my faith fits
into my loyalty to America ultimately
I'm loyal to whatever uh and so I think
this question of who do you answer to
ultimately is interesting because we
need our politicians to say my priority
is to the people who elected me who are
ultimately All American although some of
them live in different states and
therefore have their own priorities uh
the idea that someone is like well my
home country is Somalia so I like it
they're better like and JFK had to come
to West Virginia to earn those votes
from people who were very skeptical of
his Catholic ISM and he and and he did
win West Virginia and that speech that
you're talking about is worth listening
to No it's it's really powerful and I I
think it's it's something that I wish
more people would study yeah she's Omar
claims that the translations were
slanted by
propagandists yeah I've seen I've seen
reports that I'm always worried about
that when I'm seeing stuff on Twitter
like going viral and they like and it's
got you know I don't retweet them yeah
yeah because you don't know you just
don't know and now with deep fakes dude
yeah when when someone's talking into a
mic and you can't really see their mouth
and this is all you know people you're
watching the gam and I you could you
could AI deep fake anything M mhm I show
I showed Tim the video of Joe Biden in
front of a green screen with the boom
mic going through his hand anything's
fake remember that the that was that was
a weird video anything anything is fake
anything you guys remember that one
where Joe Biden walks up to the the
Press Corp whatever and he and he leans
forward and then all a sudden one of the
mics is like in front of his or no it's
like under his hand yeah it kind of
looks like it goes right through his
hand it's just very strange I as if he
was in front of a green screen I think
he is in front of green screen a but he
does film on a Sound Stage
semi but there were other angles of this
that looked normal there were there were
but I think he's either a clone
sometimes a deep fake or AI but that's
just me I don't want to derail the
conversation Shane Shane but it's true I
got I got I got to stop dude these these
unhinged conspiracies have no place
insane conversations we're clearly in a
simulation yeah thank you thank you Tim
dude I gotta be honest like I'm sitting
here watching everything going on and
I'm like yo the world's crazy well this
is I've been think this but how do we
have that perspective like is it cuz
when we were growing up things seemed
more normal but now everything's just
nuts or are we just in some kind of
simulation I was listening to one of
your bits earlier about in the 90s when
we were all younger and it seemed like a
cheerier Time the there I I think that's
true it was true but there was more of a
curtain between us and degeneracy
happening in DC and you know outward all
all over the place there's no more
curtain anymore so the gener is
everywhere it was the the noble
journalist who shielded us from the
harsh truths of DC to let all the
warmongers do all their their Waring and
you didn't have to know about it I think
we were a happier country though were
several decades ago I I don't I think I
agree I think there was a um a level of
a lot more stuff could get hidden things
like I'm grateful for social media
because it allows certain journalists
who I do trust to to bring things to
like on the other hand the downside is
the degeneracy that becomes trendy
spreads much more I'm hoping that that
degeneracy starts to Wayne soon that's
my psychotic optimism talking well there
was an article in the Atlantic uh that I
haven't finished reading so no one quote
me on it but it was talking about how
there's going to be a Christian Revival
in America it's already happening which
I find fasc well and and younger
Generations tend to be more religious I
think there was a poll out the other day
and I don't have the source that said
genen Z males are more likely to view
feminism as dangerous or bad like there
is a shift occurring but what will be
the long-terms effect because we've
already you know we've already had
people raised in the culture of fear and
mistrust
well yeah feminism should be illegal
women women should have to wear those
handmaid tail things that's
right supposed to do that what happened
to C I'm making that happen I'm not why
are you here Hannah clir he overturn
Wade they're going to agree with you
that's right the thing is that we all
have to agree that the cloak that they
wear in handmade sale the red one that's
cool that is stylish I mean being forced
to do I'm I stand by that 100% the head
thing I get maybe impractical for
driving but should women just of course
all of those women lined up to wear
masks by the way and you can't take them
off their face like don't take my mask
away the same handmaid but then they
have those scenes they in the show where
they're like do we have to wear these
masks like pick aide thinking about all
this though and like how we're kind of
becoming as a society numb to all these
shocking events that keep happening I
was thinking about that crazy
decapitation video that happened that
came out with the guy had a militia did
you write about it claimed he was
president of the country now and he
wanted Biden kidnapped you know like
that's already receding from the news
and like there's no shelf life to shock
anymore like think my because he's alive
like he got taken into alive which
normally you'd think they would film his
appearance and there be other stuff but
I mean part of is I think that he is
just so crazy that it's hard for even
mainstream media to spin I saw a couple
like magga supporter does whatever but
right he ultimately declared himself
president so I don't know super mega but
even thinking about how people are uh
the theories fracture after that video
emerges we can't even agree on that even
though there's a video of him saying
these things there's people saying
literally he's he could be MK Ultra
which is very possible it could be it
could be AI the the head could have been
a prop you know like we can't even agree
on things in the video which goes back
to George Floyd you know any anything on
video January 6 all these things so
that's the stuff that's weird the the
break started with Trump I mean it's
it's if Hillary had won in 2016 we
wouldn't be here I mean we we would
still think it was the same country from
Obama and W and I everything changed
after Trump and that's when the break
began snowballed down like and then
happened yeah lockdowns well Co wouldn't
have happened if not for Trump exactly
my foil some people thought the break
started when Kanye storm the stage at
the VMAs and took Taylor's award so
we'll save that for another podcast
that's good let's talk about Taylor
Swift everyone in the chat fires me
immediately there are there are many
things that happened the biggest impact
I believe was probably the Great
Recession that shocked the entire system
massively which resulted in Occupy Wall
Street which resulted in uh
economic shift where what are young
people able to do without without these
jobs that were lost go on the internet
and start posting BS creating all these
digital news websites that make BS
creating a generation of people who
don't want to lift heavy things and the
big shift was around this time not
necessarily the Great Recession but it's
around this time with the emergence of
social media we got the rise of
intersectionalism and postmodernism and
it was because it made money that's the
simple version algorithms promoted
things that generate rage yeah if it
makes you angry it gets clicks more than
any other emotion and politics Injustice
makes people angry so the world is
dominated by politics since then the
avatar for that anger with more more
people seeing what was going on more
more people being screwed over we get
screwed over in 2008 mostly the you know
uh genx and Boomers and older and then
you've got Barack Obama and what does he
do he doesn't help you he go there's
more war in the second term for Barack
Obama people were unsatisfied Hillary
Clinton is deeply disliked was
advocating for war and Donald Trump
represented a lot of the anger people
were feeling especially young people
with the rise of postmodernism and I
know that's for a fact because I went to
like 30 plus rallies in the 20156
election cycle and I'd ask young people
like why are you here and uh Jamesville
Wisconsin was one me memorable moment a
fight broke out and this is such such
it's so indicative of exactly what
happened you have uh man this one really
grinds my gears sorry what what rally
was it Jamesville Wisconsin no for whom
for Trump okay so I'm there and I see
some young guys and I'm like you know
what are you guys doing here why do you
support Trump and they're like the
political correctness is getting out of
control they're like we like Donald
Trump because he speaks his mind and
he's pushing back a fight broke out and
you can find these videos I believe it
was mike.com I could be wrong but there
was uh a young Progressive woman got
pepper sprayed what they did was they
ran headlines across the board saying
Trump supporter pepper sprays young
women it's true but she punched him
she she punched him in the face he
sprayed her afterwards I believe that
that's disproportionate getting punched
in the face and all you do is spray
someone with pepper spray wow punch in
the face is way worse what did they do
the interaction was about one second the
girl punches the guy he instantly sprays
so when these Al I believe it was Mike
shows this
argument there's a white Flash and then
he's spraying her with with with pepper
spray the white flash was when she
punched him they literally edited a
split second as if it was like here's
this here's the fight and here's where
he did it when in fact the whole thing
was a few seconds and they wanted to cut
out that she hit him first of course
this exemplifies exactly where we've
gone these these companies wanted to
make money we we all saw that Ryan long
bit where he's like I will sell
different footage to MSNBC or to Fox dep
on what happens and he's like if it's
you know when the protester is throwing
bottles at the cops I sell it to Fox
when the cops are attacking back I sell
it to MSNBC that's the game so when you
get this you know Progressive woman
punching a guy No One's Gonna click on
that nah your audience wants to see the
opposite Trump's the bad guy so they
manipulate the media they they did that
so many times uh sorry to cut you off I
remember I was a Hillary supporter voted
for Hillary um sorry uh but I remember
during that time in 2015 and 2016 before
he got elected and it was like we were
constantly hearing these stories about
Trump supporters throwing black people
and that's how and they would show the
footage of a bunch of you know Trump
supporters throwing a black person out
what they forgot to mention was that the
black person in many instances was a you
know kind of a radical protester who
often times was getting violent with
people they cut all that out and stupid
people like me were like oh my God Trump
supporters hate black people they're
throwing them out of rallies why did
that seem so believable to you at the
time just because you were already in
sort of like Progressive circles or what
about it was was uh because I really did
believe
that so the you have to remember that I
didn't realize how big Maga was too I
don't think any of us really did yet so
the media was representing it as this
Fringe sect of the Republican party that
was small remember he was supposed to
lose in a landslide he was supposed to
get like 3% of the vote so I thought
Maga was this radical sect of the
Republican party that was extremely
racist and bigoted that that was
reacting it was a backlash against the
black President Barack Obama these
people were it was a backlash against
game marriage rights that were that
coming to the Forefront and it seemed
believable to me that these were uh
radical white supremacist people that
were being riled up by Trump the media
kept saying Trump you know calls
Mexicans rapists he's advocating for a
Muslim ban he wants to repeal gay rights
that's what I thought the movement was
about so then they'd go out and find
these moments that they could show me
see see they're throwing black people
out they don't want want black people at
the rally and I I was like wow these
people are terrible and it did seem
believable I think once they can the
media apparatus can convince people of a
caricature of someone rather than the
real person you can convince them to
think anything about that person and
they did that so beautifully with Trump
because they're like they present this
cartoon figure on the news deceptively
edited and then they'll tell you
anything and it was it was easily
believable I didn't care about Trump or
Hillary at 2015 or 16 I didn't even vote
the first time I didn't vote was that
was the 2016 election I voted for Trump
in 2020 um but I was like noticing early
on that they were doing to Trump what
they were were doing to certain artists
that I like growing up whether it was
rappers or people in the midal community
they were turning them into a caricature
and then people were going like oh it's
a a psychotic person you know but then
you know you see the deceptively edit
videos of good people on both sides just
one example and then you're like well
that illusion shattering and then once
that shatters you kind of like there's
like a domino effect of all these things
can be they've been lying to me for
about everything I'm surprised we
haven't uh yeah yeah I voted for Obama
I'm surprised we Haven SE more def fakes
already more what more they're holding
on to those I think they're coming but
there's a certain I think like hypnosis
and brainwashing that that like do you
remember growing up and being in grade
school and you you would learn when you
were really young if you're in trouble
go find a police officer find a fireman
you know and we were kind of taught that
there's certain institutions that you
trust that are just inherently
trustworthy right and I thought that
about the media like I did not think the
media lied I I thought you know if you
watch if it's if they say it on the news
it's more than likely true and when
Trump started talking about fake news
and all this stuff I was like wow this
this dude is the devil like he's you
know he's got this Fringe group of
psychotic weirdos that are following him
and then he's he's telling them not to
trust the news not to trust the you know
whatever he was right about everything I
was primed for the fake news because I
was in eighth grade as a Marilyn Manson
fan when Coline happened and so I see
the news saying immediately Marilyn
Manson is to blame for this but I knew
him as a fan being like that doesn't
seem right he just seems like an easy
target cuz he looks a certain way I
think that's an interesting question
like when did you stop trusting the
media when did you start to think the
media could lie to you like that's a
very specific around grade but but they
still had a under a spell I think for
everybody it's different right because
if you know something is true like you
fan when did you when did I was uh I was
in uh Ferguson during the riots and CNN
I think it was Don Lemon I don't know
they said there was no tear gas they
were reporting that while I was standing
in a field of tear gas right and I'm
just like wow so weird they love it when
I was in the courtroom with Carrie Lake
I'm watching them basically catch people
on stand lying against K Lake and then
the NBC guys next to me writing a whole
new reality and I'm watching him report
on it outside I'm like we started a
chant outside to mock this man because
I'm like this is ridiculous he's he's
totally lying I'm not surprised at that
point because that was only was that
video I can't remember what the reporter
said was it was this the mostly peaceful
protest video and like there's a summer
of 2020 and there's a a building burning
behind him and you're sort of like I
don't know if you understand the words
that you're saying right and and people
may remember too in 2020 my organization
walkway we went to Dallas we were doing
rallies all over the country uh a BLM
protester came to our our rally charged
the stage uh got taken down by our
security and the police came and
arrested the BLM protester then they
came and arrested our security guard as
well so my team and I they held our
security guard for hours so we went to
the police station and find out what was
going on when we got there there were
like 30 BLM activists outside of the
police station holding a press
conference everybody was there ABC CBS
NBC Fox telmundo everyone was outside
when we showed up these this is on video
people have seen it about 20 of these
guys chased us for five blocks screaming
they were going to kill us throwing
stuff at us taking our phones smashing
them on the ground all of those media
Outlets followed us for five blocks ABC
filmed all five blocks most of the media
Outlets filmed the entire thing that
night on the news they ran a story they
ran the press conference from BLM where
BLM portrayed themselves as the victims
of racial Injustice at the walkway event
mentioned nothing about what happened
even though they filmed the entire thing
Chappelle talks about in his last
special about when he's attacked on
stage by the homeless person and then
there's basically hit pieces against
Chappelle talking to the homeless person
and making him the victim yeah dude had
a knife and what you said a second ago
about Marilyn Manson I mean that's
that's why they were able to get away
with what they got away with with Jacob
chansley the the QQ on Shaman right
because he looked unusual so they're
like perfect he looks un and the left
the left who so loves to be like you
know diversity and let people be their
own person and you know everyone's
unique whatever so you've got this guy
wearing paint whatever they're like he's
a weirdo get him get the weirdo yeah
made not after a summer of riots and
fires right you know and then this
little thing at January 6 with a guy
with a The Mask or the paint on they but
they will turn anyone into the villain
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net
for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time